hier soir le magazine d'actualités
quotidien au sommet le comédien jean
paul roux pour la promotion de son film
les tuche 4 pour de l'émission ils sont
revenus sur le meeting donné par eric
zemmour ce week-end diffusant
l'interview d'un proche du candidat en
toi de guers bonsoir antoine dherse
monsoise et porte-parole de
l'association des amis d'eric zemmour il
se trouve qu'à ce moment là le micro de
jean paul roux et est ouvert et une
injure y aurait échappé nous avons une
sécurité privée qui sera en place nos
sympathisants
vocation relayé sur les réseaux sociaux
mais coupée dans l'émission nous avons
une sécurité privée qui sera et ça
marche à tous les coups souvenez vous la
semaine dernière ce qui n'a pas échappé
à l'avocat et membre du rnd gilbert
collard chez quotidien pour cent son
micro fermé l'acteur jean paul rouve
retraite antoine diers ce porte-parole
de zemmour de feindre as tous et
antiracistes ont un drôle de rapport
avec la race et vous êtes vous choqué
par les propos de jean paul rouve contre
antoine vient ce proche d'eric zemmour
antoine a commencé à antoine hier très
bien s'ils n'ont pas trop te laisse tout
va bien pas trop triste bon c'est pas
agréable ben c'est pas agréable de se
faire appeler par ce qu'ils ont vu ça
sur les réseaux équipe signal j'ai été
pas vraiment choqué pas vraiment vexé
mais vraiment la question c'est pourquoi
se croit-il autorisée
qui avait bien comme ça vous le savez en
toi et je te lis toujours dit et tu le
sais eric zemmour c'est pas ma tasse de
thé mais je ne discute avec une glace
pas ma tasse de thé il le sait la
tourette voilà tout autre site pas ma
tasse de thé mais je discute avec toi
non mais sérieux discuter même si on est
opposée sur plein de choses mais on
discute on sait jamais très loin et on
n'a jamais été n'a jamais eu des
comportements bien moi les donneurs de
leçons c'est pour moi c'est les pires et
jean paul rouve ça a toujours été un
donneur de leçons d'honneur je vais vous
donner un exemple sur dangbo jean paul
ont plus jean paul rouve il l'a dit
parce qu'ils croyaient qu'ils n'étaient
pas l'antenne comme d'habitude jean paul
rouve façon s'il avait du courage se
saurait je raconte un truc moi l'année
dernière jean paul roux fait une
interview dans paris match où je sais
plus et où il me fera casse mais comme
il a peur que je l'appelle le lendemain
pour le fracasser il prend les devants
et il m'envoie un texto tout gentil en
disant ah mais c'est pas moi qui ai dit
ça c'est le pari et c'est le journaliste
tu verra demain une interview qui sort
deux mois et c'est le journaliste quitte
à fracasser les tuyaux etc ça c'est le
journaliste qui m'a fracassé groupe hot
était en fait t'as rien dit mais c'est
le journaliste il s'est glissé permis
d'écrire à ta place que tu allais bien
donc il m'a appelé après que j'ai vue
d'une interview forcément j'ai vu là
voilà hemayma fracassé voilà j'ai aimé
plus de nouvelles mais c'est vrai que
c'est voilà c'est un donneur de leçons
voilà problème on a passé un très bon
comédien mais c'est vrai que c'est un
donneur de leçons moi les mecs comme ça
les donneurs de leçon je peux plus voilà
c'est je sais pas pour vous mais c'est
insupportable on essaie de respecter
tout le monde on peut ne pas être opposé
moi je les ai dit voilà antoine eric
zemmour on est opposé voilà mes jambes
les donneurs de leçons mais c'est vrai
et si hollande va me répondre relation
charrie ya pas de problème franchement
c'est moi et voilà on y arrive on dire
là se dit les choses mais les donneurs
de leçons ce sont les pires et jean paul
roux il fait partie voilà de cette
petite catégorie de gens qui se prennent
pour des donneurs de leçons voilà et ça
je n'en peux plus que souvent pensé
qu'il gardait c'est méprisant ce qu'il a
dit c'est lâche et c'est insultant pour
vous moi je suis profondément choqué
parce que de quel droit feindra c'est
une insulte vous pourriez l'attaqué
d'ailleurs un power-play bien sûr nom et
vos sensations animaux diffamation mais
encore là bas c'est attaquable en tout
cas ça
diffusée sur les voilà je trouve cela
infâme parce que ces gens là c'est tout
le mépris bobos des artistes qui qui qui
méprise je trouve le peuple les gens qui
ont le droit de croire en zemmour qui
ont le droit d'écouter ce monsieur qu'on
soit d'accord ou pas donc moi je suis
totalement choqués et vous avez ma
solidarité par rapport à cet ingénieur
ou de l'avc le mépris que bien sûr aussi
méprisant avec moi qui suis un
spectateur de ses films comme harry ou
d'autres français mais en fait on se
rend compte de l'envers du décor il
pensait ne pas être entendus ah c'est ça
le plus grand mépris mais aussi jean
paul rouve pense être entendu leur ai
jamais dit ça on le connaît voilà quand
paul rouve ça va mais gaffe tu oui alors
oui et donc non juste savait que les
artistes on les a pas beaucoup entendus
s'engager depuis depuis des mois et on
peut être évidemment content qu'on des
mois mais c'est vrai que là pour le coup
ils disent rien en public et par
derrière il vous insulte c'est pas une
façon de faire il ya une autre époque où
les artistes pour franchement s'engager
disait ce qu'il pensait poliment et y
avait une vraie fonction aujourd'hui
c'est perdu on a entendu personne de
zemmour et on aurait pu les routes ont
beaucoup derrière ça mais l'entente mais
devant un public personne personne
s'élever à 10 moi j'aime pas ce qu'ils
disent ne pas se quitter même pas 5
antoine vous avez affecté quand même par
cette insulte un petit peu bien fait au
delà de moi moi je commence à avoir là
mais quand même la mine un peu tanné
mois 5 c'est tous les autres militants
tous les we met ta famille faisait ma
famille ici relooker sa famille passait
chez un peu désagréable mais enfin c'est
ce que tous les soutiens d'eric zemmour
vive vous avez vu tanguy hier on a un
peu le sentiment que quand on soutient
eric zemmour ça autorise les mises aux
normes et public bonjour le public qui
de tout à mes seins qu'un comédien voilà
sur une émission comme ça se permettent
de donner son avis et vous traitez comme
ça franchement c'est insupportable oui
non moi je suis pas d'accord avec ce
monsieur vous le savez un mais en
revanche je suis non mais je suis désolé
non c'est pas grave du tout mais je suis
désolé en revanche quand vous est traité
comme ça cela dit je tiens à souligner
que c'était hors antenne est alors
élancée pire
c'est pire il
ajouté non pas du tout alors j'ai reçu
le label d'anti ce matin ça veut dire
qu'ils disent est vraiment si pour ces 6
1 sur wii maladière antennes alors donc
enclave en soit il est hypocrite c'est
hors antenne qui sillonnait parfois on
reçoit des gens on est correct et après
on dit là je peux pas attaquer quelqu'un
oui mais voilà ça oui mais bojan toile
le vrai truc étonnant ok c'était en tête
mais j'ai reçu ce matin un sms du
producteur de l'émission qui me dit
c'était hors antenne ça compte pas c'est
un problème technique et je relis son
message est en fait il il a juste oublié
de s'excuser oui c'est pas que désolé
donc en fait je n'ai même pas une excuse
ni de l'émission au quotidien pas plus
que de jean paul rouve on me dirait
c'était en rente elle je me suis lâché
je vous appelle monsieur d'hyères je
suis désolé excusez moi emballé c'est
pesé voilà voilà rien même pas une
excuse franchement je pense que ces gens
ce que tu attends des excuses publiques
le jean paul rouve ben je trouve que
quand on est un moment et jeff tuer on
peut déconner j'ai déjà fait du chemin
ce serait mesquin maroc et franchement
il devrait faire s'il était marrant
c'est marrant mais je
pense pas qu'il va le faire non je pense
n'est déjà fait et maintenant je me
rends que l'or maintenant comme il va
passer soir vers peut-être le faire mais
bon je pense que ça y est c'est déjà
fini espérons mais j'y crois pas en fait
vraiment c'est la gauche bien pensante
les bonhommes sont là-haut et il nous
regarde en bas comme ça avec plein de
mépris